ainsi mon papa mais voyez lui qui me
disait toujours si j'étais en france il
ya des choses que je l'aimerais faire
aller visiter la grande synagogue de
notre dame de paris et dîner chez
maxim's je veux pas paraître je suis
chez maxim's et il est mon invité titre
posthume mettrait d'hôtel
pour commencer vous allez nous donner
c'est pas donné ben c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on va chez maxim ce conflit est
là vous allez nous donner et comment si
j'attends quelqu'un et non j'attends
personnes j'ai des jeunes avec moi même
comprendre la même chose alors vous
allez nous donner in et un bal des
champignons et non attendez démarquer
page et me méfie des champignons ça me
rappelle que j'ai un ami qu'il est mort
deux jours après l'avoir mangé des
champignons dans la marmite et phalloïde
moyon notre et chose araignées des
mérous la santé des bêtes oh là là où
quand je pense que ça existe des
araignées comme ça dans la mer avec des
patrons rouge et belligène comme les
jambes de ma concierge
ah bah voilà ça ça me plaît vous allez
me donner in et saumon fumé avec
supplément
qu'est ce qui va vous en donner comme
supplément un as et en supplément des
prix c'est pourquoi il est en supplément
des prix parce qu'il vient d'où des
scandinavie si je comprends bien c'est
moi qui les paye son voyage il n'y en a
pas un qui vient des petits prêts non
parce que les poissons qui viennent de
loin j'ai mes filles
il arrive souvent fatigués par les
voyages y en a pas mal et sait pas
comment ça s'appelle la bestiole avec
les pinces la caisse a commencé avec un
cas et pas par la crevette la laque avis
il y en a pas ça une crise assez l'aoma
à l'amérique à barrichello bra la roma à
l'américain ben voila je vais prendre ça
et on verra offir un désir jeudi on
verra offir masi et fit comprendre les
français c'est dur
j'ai pris là aux mains parce que y'a pas
des prix on dirait bien pourrait nous
offrir l'apéritif quand même à ces prix
là nous n'est pas des sauvages tout même
mais bon je me suis vous êtes coin
sommelier et il n'y a pas de sot métier
et moi je suis cantonniers est assez
pour les verges avon je croyais que les
matelas
ça c'est 10 homélie bon écoute et
aujourd'hui je vais pas boire les vins
des métiers tout le monde je vais un vin
de qualité très supérieure
je regarde pas à la dépense mais je vais
le meilleur et le moins cher
alors qu'est ce que vous allez me donner
des bons dans les grands bordeaux
d'accord dernière page allons-y
qu'est ce que je lis la chaffoteaux et
maury à château de pouilly
avant j'aurais dû prendre mes lunettes
et la chatonnay dis pas tiens il fait
dans les vins aussi
la carafe d'eau est gratuite
bon on va déjà la prendre la carafe
d'eau est alors pour colorer un peu
écoutez moi je me connais pas je vous
fais confiance je ne connais pas qu'est
ce que vous allez me proposer les bons
et un mouton rothschild voilà une bonne
idée oui comment si je les préfère dans
une coin dans une grande tv et non pas
dans une grande cuvette et donne dans
une petite bouteille ça c'est plus un
petit quart à pau comment vous en avez
est millésimé 1900 combien 1929 il vous
en reste encore 17 époque
moi c'est pareil dit dont il me reste
des anciens modèles des caleçons
molletonnés j'arrive pas à les liquider
et vous laissons le dire combien 1500
francs 15 points c'est pas cher
3500 nouveaux 159 points vous êtes sûr
que c'est pas les taux longs cent
cinquante mille points pour une
bouteille de ben y'a des croisières
italien d'épicés pendant dix jours
c'est un coup abandonné la prostate ça
faites la carte bleue ici fait pas la
quatrième de la carte orange bon écoute
et amener mois déjà la casa dos et puis
on va réfléchir si j'ai encore soit pour
m'apprendre et ben voilà ça me rappelle
qu'un gestuelle avec mon père dans une
haie grande restaurant qu'est ce qu'ils
aiment regarder comme un fou du groupe
apavou je me parle à moi et on est allé
dans un grand restaurant des deux
garçons la diversité de vins il
attendait derrière il mon père dit
qu'est ce qu'il est à la tente derrière
moi avec la bouteille à la main il m'a
versé un fond de verre il faudra pas
qu'il va mêler compté pour environ six
lots à voilà les homards à l'américain
la bande à la voilà voilà
avaya piste car casques et des eaux
marle
donc j'ai dit il ya prise de kaka ce que
des rumeurs là qu'est ce qu'il est
arrivé lé tout casser il a fait un
atterrissage forcé génome à l'américain
qu'il appelait l anglaise avant
d'arriver dans mon assiette la main qui
pense la bauma ça dépend ce que j'ai
payé pour les dépenses non comment ils
se sont bâties dans les viviers et ben
alors apportez moi le vainqueur par les
26 bon sens